[Music]
every year 10,000 babies are abandoned
in Romania's hospitals since the fall of
church sq 18 months ago around 10,000
children have been adopted the Romanians
are trying to introduce a fairer and
more efficient way of finding family
homes for the tens of thousands of
children in institutions
a material normally not the fact a grill
she's muttered in this crisp and
cassandra Forte Forte and Moulton
gossipy part booze loaf is each a
reference for the multicast a party
Iran syndrome travel camera Tara
pregnancy Pandora navara Shinkansen
company officially joke or even Tom
shatrova the universe' pokhara territory
murat practice my s'mores
they know no prospective she mod dis
bracket hospital aboard huh huh and some
about wound up as well
[Music]
claudia was born with one arm and placed
in state care as an infant
her mother died from complications
arising from childbirth she grew up in
four orphanages in different parts of
Romania until she was 18
effective Iran while anyone we wrap up
like the governor anymore a huge system
of orphanages was created in Romania
during the communist dictatorship of
Nicolae Ceausescu's his dogmatic vision
turned motherhood into a state's duty as
he attempted to increase the population
in order to fuel the economy as the
population increased by more than four
million he exported food to pay off the
national debt while he rationed supplies
at home the Romanian people were left
hungry while Ceausescu built himself
huge palaces in december 1989 a violent
revolution began within weeks the regime
was defeated and its dictator executed
the world then discovered the most
haunting legacy of Ceausescu's Romania
the fate of over 100,000 children
abandoned in the country's dilapidated
orphanages negative energy system
subjected to from personal disabilities
Nalla locally uh saddam on partial
potato to grill our ominous article a no
more doing more PPC piccata consummated
a retardant muy fortunately she motto
cooperated felicia today Claudia works
as a supervisor at the yarn Holborn
institution in Yash Romania's
second-largest city it's the same
institution where she lived as a
teenager 20 years ago
eunho bond is due to close in 2019 to
vivace 1070 the Johan bond where he
comes in Baraka removable and JSON /
regret ah
between the materiality lemma which HR
this all day over at Ishida river say
just over 7,000 children live in
Romania's 163 institutions all of which
will be closed within the next decade
it's part of a global shift to shut down
large institutions which can often
reduce a child's potential and expose
them to abuse and exploitation the
charity hope in homes for children has
worked with successive Romanian
governments to close down 31 orphanages
an institution like your whole bunch
should be closed they do not offer
family love they do not offer the child
what a child needs most which is to
belong to a family to have a mother and
the father to feel special it's about a
simple paradigm shift we look at where
the children come from and we have a
program to prevent child separation from
families we look at where they go to and
we see how many of them could be
we integrated back into their own
families extended families are in foster
care for those which foster care is an
option some former residents of the yarn
hall barn institution have already made
the transition to a new family home
funded by the state
the Manolis sisters had lived at yarn
Hoban for five years
following a family tragedy having raised
their own children on Conant Theodore
and Mary chica decided to foster their
five nieces no shape for summer it
shattered Brittany I mean or should
there be some in jammu not just general
Cara me no issue no matter except except
economy since watch dr. su desperate
says the bash a girl's my guess is gonna
polish a sphere a woman sukemasa it's an
illegal Paris fella to the very shores
feeling ravenous knows this part right
so did you doc thought of was
unwittingly lost if I jump in Mike's
real assad the Manolis sisters have been
lucky around the globe over two million
children still live in orphanages for
those who cannot be reintegrated with
their families their future hangs in the
balance
what feels koppikhar us books to Calaca
City Paris printer in Hanoi when you
know plane largely bring making a
diverse though we've mostly come up with
the news present new patterns in couples
purgatory Halloween rector not the party
should be familiar he can you okay many
older children are likely to be
relocated not into families but into
smaller state-run group homes after
years and institutions some can find
this overwhelming the global shift away
from state institutional care has its
risks finding new homes for vulnerable
young people can only work if their
well-being can be ensured as they make
the transition to independent life
outside of state care Joan of web-portal
no pressure the simple effective drugs
Cal Poly insular Calle practic say
crezcan and soon our formulation on
Sunnis totally effective Totten vermin
you
you